كل ما يريده طفل
كان لديه أصدقاء كان يعرفه الفتيات
اللائي أحبه
وقبل أن يضغط على الزناد ،
كان
عليه أن ينشر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من قام
بإطفاء الأنوار
ويبدو الأمر كما
لو وجدنا أن هاتفه لا
يزال في يده.
الدم عليها وكل شيء
ولكن أعني
أنه كان مدمنًا عليها
لدرجة أن لحظاته الأخيرة في حياته كانت
تدور حول النشر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نشأ CJ Dawley مع أربعة أشقاء في
التلال المتدحرجة
لأصدقاء وعائلة ويسكونسن يقولون إنه كان نشطًا
سعيدًا  والممثل الكوميدي للمجموعة ولكن
دون علم الكثيرين كان CJ يعاني في
4 يناير 2015 ، انسحب إلى
غرفة نومه وتوفي منتحراً رسالة
مغادرته مكتوبة على
ظرف خطاب قبول الكلية ،
هل تعلم
أيًا من الصراعات التي واجهها مع
بلده  الصحة العقلية سواء كانت مرتبطة
بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل عام فقط ،
لم يكن لديه أي دليل على أنه كان
مريضًا على الإطلاق
منذ وفاة عائلة cj تقول
نظرة فاحصة على منشوراته على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وعلى الإنترنت  تظهر المحادثات أن
إدمانه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أدى إلى
مشاكل في صورة الجسد والحرمان من النوم والاكتئاب
لدرجة أنه كان مدمنًا لدرجة أنه لم يكن
ينام في الليل
وكان على هاتفه
طوال الوقت
الذي يقاضي فيه والديه الآن
الشركة الأم snapchat snap and metta الشركة الأم
من facebook و
instagram ، تطلق الدعوى على instagram facebook و
snapchat منتجات خطيرة وفعالة بشكل غير معقول
أدت في النهاية
إلى انتحار CJ ،
لم أتحدث كثيرًا عن
هذا الأمر ، لكنني سأشاركك
ما حدث في تلك الليلة ،
لقد ضاعنا نوعًا ما  من حيث cj
بقدر ما نعلم أنه ذهب للعمل
10 30 في الليل بابي
تقريبًا قد تم خلعه من المفصلات
مثل مقبض الباب حتى لم يتحول
صراخ ابنتي ،
شانون بدأت تصرخ عليه بالفم
وهي تخبرني
أبي
كان بإمكاني أن أنقذه الدم كان
يخرج من أنفه
بينما كانت تحاول إنعاش
شقيقها الذي مات منذ
ثماني ساعات.
من بين عدد متزايد
من العائلات التي تقاضي شركات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بسبب الوفاة والإصابة غير المشروعة ،
ماثيو بيرجمان هو أحد المحامين البارزين في الدعوى القضائية
ومؤسس
مركز قانون ضحايا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
ما نأمله هو أن تقوم شركات وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بتصميم منتجات أكثر أمانًا.
أي سابقة قانونية للوفاة غير المشروعة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
فهناك عدد قليل من القضايا ، لكن هذا يمثل
كثيرًا جدًا من التقاضي المتطور ، فنحن الآن فقط
نتعلم بالضبط ما
هي هذه الخوارزميات ، ونحن الآن لا
نطور ونمتلك
البحث العلمي
الذي  يدعم علاقة السبب والنتيجة
بين إدمان وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وأزمة الصحة العقلية بين
المراهقين ، وتأتي الدعاوى القضائية بعد أشهر فقط من ظهور
الآلاف من وثائق الفيسبوك المسربة
التي أظهرت أن كلا من فيسبوك وإنستغرام
يعلمان أن خوارزميات منتجاتهما يمكن أن
تكون ضارة للأطفال في مكالمة أرباح
اقترح مارك زوكربيرج  أنه
تم اختيار المستندات بشكل انتقائي
لرسم صورة مزيفة أ  حول الشركة ،
ما الذي يتعلق بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي
تؤثر بشكل مباشر على عقل المراهق أكثر
من المراهقين البالغين
من المرجح أن يشعروا
بتأثير الدوبامين ولا يعني ذلك أن كل
جانب من جوانب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يزيد
الدوبامين ولكن هناك الكثير من
الأدلة  تشير إلى أن الدوبامين
يتم إطلاقه
للعديد من المراهقين عندما يجدون شيئًا
مجزيًا على منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بهم ،
وقد أظهرت الدراسات أن المراهقين الذين يقضون
وقتًا أطول على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هم أكثر
عرضة للإبلاغ عن مشكلات الصحة العقلية
مثل الاكتئاب والقلق التي يعاني منها
المراهقون  وجد أنه
يعاني بشكل متزايد من
حوالي سن 25 عامًا عندما يتشكل
الدماغ
بشكل كامل ، وبالتالي قد يؤدي
ذلك إلى استجابة المراهقين بشكل أسرع
لشيء أسرع للنشر بشكل
أسرع للقيام بشيء
قد يكون ضارًا لأنفسهم
وللآخرين.  حول الفوز أو الخسارة ، فإننا
جميعًا نخسر الآن
ولكن إذا تمكنا من
جعلهم يغيرون الخوارزمية لواحد ج  إذا تم إنقاذ
طفل واحد ،
فسيكون الأمر يستحق العناء
، ورفض كل من meta and snap التعليق
مشيرًا إلى أن الدعوى القضائية جارية ، لكنهما قالا لشبكة
CNN إنهم يقدمون
موارد للصحة العقلية والوقاية من الانتحار لمستخدميهم
[موسيقى]
هذه هي جميع البطاقات التي حصلت عليها
في  البريد
الذي
تعرفه وهذه هي
بطاقته ،
أنا أحب دكتور هيل الذي
كنت أخرجه الأشياء إلى المرآب ،
أنت تعرف الصناديق وعندما دخلت
كان يقف
في المدخل كان ينظر إلى
هاتفه وأتمنى فقط أن أفعل
أمسكته وعانقته وكنت
أعرف فقط لرؤيته
حزينًا جدًا على
هاتفه وكانت هذه آخر لحظة رأيته
لديه عائلة كبيرة ، ليس من السهل
الاتفاق على ما يجب فعله بكل شيء
تعرفه يقوله شخص واحد إنه جيد
كما تعلم ، قم بتحريك كل شيء ،
نعم للحصول على السلام ولكن شخصًا آخر
لا تريد عدم احترام رأيهم
حتى لا تتمكن من تنظيفه وهذا
أكبر شيء تعرفه ، أعني
ماذا تفعل بالجوائز التي حصل عليها
لهم ماذا سنفعل بهم
أحاول ألا أحضر إلى هنا أبدًا لأنني
أصبح الأمر صعبًا للغاية ،
فستكون شخصًا محظوظًا واحدًا من
الوالدين المحظوظين أنجبت طفلًا من هذا القبيل
ويجب أن أذكر نفسي طوال الوقت
عندما أبدأ في الشعور بالمرارة
والغضب من ذلك  لقد أمضيتها في هذا
القدر من الوقت
، من الصعب
كيف تأخذ
جزءًا من قلبك
لا يمكنك
استبداله
بك